bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero el
ascenso del voto hacia la ultraderecha
francesa en la primera vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales ha sido de lo
más analizado en los últimos días de
hecho uno de los partidos que
representan a esta corriente ideológica
la agrupación nacional de marine lepén
será quien se vuelva a enfrentar contra
el presidente y candidato en manuel
macrón en el balotaje del próximo 24 de
abril pero de dónde proviene la
fortaleza de la ultraderecha francesa y
cuál ha sido su recorrido para
convertirse en una alternativa real a la
presidencia sus orígenes se remontan a
los inicios de la década de 1970 desde
el final de la segunda guerra mundial la
extrema derecha había quedado
prácticamente marginada del sistema
político pero jean marie le pen padre de
la actual candidata ma jing lepén
consiguió reunir bajo el mismo paraguas
a personas decepcionadas con el papel
del estado en la guerra de independencia
de argelia ultra conservadores
tradicionales y nostálgicos del régimen
colaborador de la alemania nazi conocido
como la francia de vichy
algo que sin embargo nos sirvió para
aglutinar un gran número de apoyos
durante los primeros 10 años esta
formación ultraderechista recibió votos
residuales debido a la radicalidad de
algunos de sus miembros posturas que
rozaban el antisemitismo o el racismo
alejaron a la mayoría del electorado de
la época pero la situación comenzó a
cambiar lentamente a mediados de los 80
para esta época el estado del bienestar
francés comenzó a sufrir los primeros
reveses y la reconversión industrial
hizo que miles de personas perdieran su
trabajo
en este contexto comenzó a surgir un
clima de desconfianza y decepción en una
parte del electorado francés que se
sentía disconforme con el sistema este
voto alternativo fue recogido por el
frente nacional y voto a voto jean
maggie lepén logró rozar el 14,5 por
ciento de las papeletas en 1988 y el 15%
en 1995 es así como a partir de la
década de 1990
el frente nacional comenzó a ser una
alternativa real para millones de
franceses y esto se reflejó en las
elecciones de 2002 el discurso
antiinmigración y contra el
establecimiento pólit llevo al frente
nacional a lograr casi un 17 por ciento
de los votos y pasar por primera vez en
su historia a la segunda vuelta este
resultado unió a todas las formaciones
políticas contra jean maggie le pen
algo que hizo que su contrincante
político jacques chirac obtuviera el 82
por ciento de los votos a su favor y
ganará la reelección
es llamar y lepe en el responsable de la
inseguridad del desempleo de los altos
impuestos el despilfarro de nuestros
recursos de la corrupción de la
inmigración desmedida en la quiebra de
nuestros trabajadores ellos son los
responsables los poseedores del sistema
los que gobiernan tan mal
2 pero la elección de 2002 solo sirvió
para evidenciar cuál era el techo
electoral de esta formación los
siguientes comicios en 2007 no fueron
buenos y ahí es cuando entró en acción
su hija y sustituta ma jin lepén ella
fue la encargada de cambiar la imagen
del partido eliminando parte de los
discursos más radicales de jean maggie
le pen para ensanchar la base electoral
aunque el fondo ideológico del frente
nacional siguió siendo de ultraderecha
para los siguientes años el contexto
político benefició a marine lepén la
unión europea y la política tradicional
comenzaron a sufrir un descrédito entre
la población eventos como la crisis
económica de 2008 o la crisis migratoria
de 2015 que generó un enorme debate
dentro de la unión europea en torno a
qué hacer con los millones de refugiados
de medio oriente que llegaron ese año
favorecieron al discurso de la
ultraderecha que se concentró en el
miedo a la incertidumbre económica y en
el rechazo a la inmigración
ni siquiera me involucraré en el debate
sobre la relación costo ingreso de la
inmigración sé que es terrible para
nuestro sistema de seguridad social para
nuestro cuidado de la salud para nuestro
sistema educativo y para nuestras
fuerzas de seguridad sólo su aumento de
votos hizo que en las presidenciales de
2017 el frente nacional llegara a
segunda vuelta y se enfrentará contra
emmanuel macrón ma jin le pen obtuvo
mejores resultados que su padre en 2002
más de un tercio de los votantes
franceses optaron por ella en segunda
vuelta un resultado histórico que
traería consecuencias
la primera cambiar el nombre de la
formación de frente nacional a
agrupación nacional la segunda
promocionar una imagen de moderación en
un contexto de declive total de los
partidos tradicionales franceses para
absorber sus votos la agrupación
nacional se convirtió en un partido con
mucho votante de áreas rurales y
semirurales su fuerza mayoritariamente
reside en el este del país pero proviene
de dos corrientes muy diferentes en el
norte recibe los votos de regiones
industriales y rurales en declive
mientras que en la costa mediterránea
logra el voto de clases medias altas
conservadoras y críticas con la
inmigración sin embargo su fuerza en
grandes ciudades y la costa atlántica es
más limitada en las elecciones de 2022
ma jin lepén mantuvo la estrategia de
parecer más moderada aunque sin cambiar
la base ideológica ultraderechista de su
partido algo que funcionó gracias a la
aparición de eric se move un candidato
aún más radical que suavizó la imagen
del epen y a centrarse en un discurso
económico una imagen que puede hacer que
la segunda vuelta de este 24 de abril
contra emmanuel macrón sea mucho más
reñida y que dependa del voto por el que
opten los que en primera vuelta
prefirieron a la izquierdista y al look
bellinzone con esto concluimos gracias
por compartir y comentar estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]